a smartphone is like a black box it's
jam-packed with technology but you can't
see any of it it does kind of make you
wonder what's under there anyway a new
app from tiny Bob called everything
machine wants to help you find out the
app which costs three dollars on iOS
pops visit to your smartphone and lets
you use its components you know the
stuff like a camera light microphone and
gyroscope to build totally new machines
using a visual programming language you
just drag and drop these inputs and
outputs into order it can take some
trial and error to get it right but
that's part of the learning process once
you figure it out though you can make
almost anything imaginable you can turn
on a light with a swipe or take a video
with the tap want to change the way that
video looks just add a modifier pretty
cool right you can increase the
complexity of your machine by adding
more components and logic gates but our
favorite is an old standby turns out the
app makes for a killer digital whoopee
cushion
you